at the end of March this year NASA
astronaut scott Kelly and Russian
cosmonaut Mikhail Kornienko launched
into space to start a year-long mission
at the International Space Station and
they did this to test the long-term
effects of space travel on the human
body this will be the longest trip ever
taken by a NASA astronaut most trips
usually lasts between four to six months
there are a bunch of issues with
spending time in space that we already
know about muscles waste away and
there's bone loss and circulatory system
troubles it's amazing how your body
adapts to this environment and how it
remembers actually being here
space programs have always had ways of
preparing astronauts for space itself
there's underwater practice there's
parachute training there's even this
airplane nicknamed the vomit comet that
simulate zero-g but staying healthy in
space is a bit different exercise is a
big issue on earth our muscles and bones
stay strong because we have to
constantly fight against gravity without
gravity they get weak and that can
prevent astronauts from doing important
physical tasks on the job to prevent
this they're required to do up to two
and a half hours of exercise per day
strapped into cycling machines
treadmills and resistance lifting
machines during long periods in space
astronauts also develop a weakened
immune system it doesn't adapt the way
it does back on earth which leaves
astronauts prone to infection due to
immune system dysregulation and this is
a pretty recent discovery scientists
aren't exactly sure what causes this to
happen it could be any combination of
lack of sleep zero-gravity radiation and
isolation even beyond the physical
complications the psychological aspect
is significant two astronauts are in
tight closed conditions with other
people and their days are not defined by
natural light the space station orbits
earth every 90 minutes which comes out
to about 16 times per day even just
getting a good night's rest can be
difficult over 75% of astronauts report
using sleeping pills regularly Scott
Kelly's twin brother Mark is a retired
astronaut and he's serving as a live
subject of comparison for the effects of
spending time in space and the more we
understand about this the closer we get
to longer and bigger projects in the
frontier
you